how many people would you say that
you've managed to completely dear
adelies as it were I'd say around two
dozen over six years just time-consuming
it's very time-consuming but but you
don't look at it like that yeah you're
dealing with a human being so it's a
privilege in that sense and
time-consuming because presumably you
are trying to flip a mindset that
doesn't just take weeks to have to
change what you're David this is there's
ideas that been embedded for years and
this is a worldview that you're dealing
with this is an whether someone's yeah
you're not changing their favorite color
yeah you're going in and you're you're
dealing with a worldview and you're
trying to take them from a place where
they view themselves as part of a group
and bring them into the rest of humanity
getting to the rest of the world see
they're not separate from them so how do
you do it how do you deer Attica lies
someone well you with this is a it's
about sincerity and it's about integrity
and it's about going in and sitting with
the person and taking their identity
which is Muslim and then teaching them
that that Islam is actually about
understanding Allah as the infinitely
loving and no and from a traditional
perspective in Islam you can only know
Allah through mercy and compassion and
the their understanding of Islam they're
very politicized understanding is
something that post-colonial if that
makes sense
Saudi news as well linguistics with
regards to the teachings of Islam
doesn't challenge that yes I mean what
this gets into is this when we're
talking about post-colonial was actually
talking about the fact that this is
about not just not a misinterpretation
because everyone uses this this term
misinterpretation of Islam we're
actually talking about mistranslation
because modern Arabic isn't the same as
traditional Arabic so key to this as
well then from what you're saying is the
translation
do you mean from the teachings of Quran
or of the Quran is that where things
have gone wrong well Islam is an oral
tradition which means it's supposed to
be taught teacher-to-student you know
the fact that you've got this what's
called democratization of information
meaning that people are picking up and
reading and interpreting for themselves
is actually something that's alien to
traditional Islam is that I'm supposed
to be taught teacher to stew to to
student and that teacher to student
relationship is something that connects
all the way back so there's a
historically verifiable chain going back
to the Prophet Muhammad himself so you
don't get these very modern day
interpretation you you see if if I give
you an example if I've had a bad day and
I pick up a newspaper and I read about a
millionaire footballer missing the goal
I'm going to be bitter thinking to
myself I'll become much he gets paid and
he's missed a goal if I've had a good
day and I see the same news report I'm
gonna think oh why they're being so hard
on him look all the goals he scored
before and that's all to do with my
interpretation on that day now when
you're talking about linguistics and
you're talking about a sensory
understanding so an understanding that
we have in English words what's called a
latinized understanding where what I can
touch taste and see is real and then
where you have the is a traditional
Islamic understanding which is
collective it's a very collective
understanding that goes into
understanding the universe from the
perspective of your interconnection but
the way it seems to evolve that and in
the D radicalization process if you like
is you're emphasizing the teachings of
Islam in the way that it connects
everybody so you're trying to connect
that extremists to the rest of the world
these individuals are often part of the
tight community group but the difference
here is is that us and
yeah this idea that you're worshipping
this this god that wants you to fight
them because you're the chosen ones and
then and it's a very very group
orientated us and then type of thought
process but so you challenge that yeah
but we got we speak to about the fact
that Islam is actually about the
interconnection not just between you and
humanity but between your nature as well
yeah when you look at traditional Islam
actually describes humanity from the
point of view that if one part of it
hurts all of it hurts so how do you get
them initially to engage with that
what's your first step if you like well
we're coming with with the legitimacy of
representing the world's foremost
Islamic scholars we're also coming with
the legitimacy of having the mainstream
community yeah we represent millions of
people around the world this isn't some
this is a some alien ideology that I'm
talking to you about this is what the
majority of Muslims believe even though
they might not be able to put it into
words but what we're dealing with is
we're dealing with people who are
imposters coming and hijacking your
tradition yeah they're reading and
quoting from books in front of them
whether we're they don't you even
understand the linguistic context of
what they're reading so they don't
understand the context of what's written
in front of them you know they're often
a lot of what's being read and I'm
saying 99% of it is analogous so when
you've got that in front of you okay but
what is the context of that analogy in
the first place because if you've read
it as it is it doesn't make sense
so this obviously doesn't take hours of
discussion this is weeks this is months
this is you yes yeah with some people
it's years but that well with but it
isn't about years because let me get
back let me rephrase up and put it in in
in its proper context that you're there
to help and help doesn't have it doesn't
have an expiry date on it and this isn't
a case of okay you're deer a declines
now it's though you're part of this
community now what you need